i'm joined now by tulip sadiq nazanin's
local mp who has of course been deeply
involved in the campaign to free her
very good to talk to you tulip sneak and
uh you tweeted some pictures a picture
of nazine on the plane on the way back
home and i get guess a bit like the rest
of us it's only when you see that
documentary evidence that after so many
false dawns you actually believe it's
happening
absolutely darham and as you say it's
been so many false storms during the six
years that we've been campaigning for
her we've dealt with three prime
ministers and five foreign secretaries
and i just saw her husband richard
radcliffe in parliament before
he headed off actually in a car to a
secret location
me to meet his wife and to be reunited
with her
and we were just laughing about the
number of times he had been in
parliament i had taken him into the
chamber because i was in the chamber
asking for nazim to be released
and this time i stood in the chamber and
i said nasalina is coming home so all i
can say is i'm so happy and i'm so happy
for their family yeah we can only
imagine the joy of richard and of course
gabriella their little girl let's talk
more though about richard's role in all
this
originally i i know um you know him very
well indeed i've interviewed him over
the years originally he was told wasn't
he you know leave this to us
leave it to the foreign office leave it
to the diplomats we do this through back
channels don't make too much of a fuss
he eventually then decided right this
isn't going to work
that's right so he was told when his
wife was initially detained which was on
the 3rd of april 2016 six years ago he
was told that he should stay quiet the
foreign office will deal with it and
that if he stayed quiet he would see
some movement on her case now rich
contacted me soon after because he said
to me that he didn't think there would
be any movement on the case and he was
very very worried about his wife because
bear in mind she was in solitary
confinement during that time so he had
no contact with her
he was very worried that the regime
would just disappear her effectively she
would be disappeared and he would just
never see her again so he started this
campaign and i took my cue from him
because i wouldn't have campaigned he
had felt for any reason that we should
keep this information confidential
i took my cue from him and initially it
was quite difficult actually to get
journalists interested in this case and
it was quite difficult to make too much
noise about it
it all changed a year later when the now
prime minister then foreign secretary
made an enormous blunder in front of the
foreign affairs select committee and
suddenly everyone was interested in the
case so i suppose the very faint silver
lining of boris johnson's blunder
was that everyone started talking about
nasa's name zagari radcliff everyone
started being interested in the case and
we got more and more coverage and i
genuinely think it was the publicity and
the coverage that made the government do
something about the case and the payment
of this debt to iran around about 400
million pounds going back 40 years and
more and the role of the current foreign
secretary liz trust first of all indeed
admitting that the uk owed this to the
government of iran
that's right so in the six years that we
campaigned and the countless foreign
secretaries we met and the ministers
that we met refused to believe us when
we talked about the link between nasa's
imprisonment and the debt that we are
iran as a country now
what i would tell you is that when nazim
was actually in prison in even prison
the people who captured her said to her
the reason you're being imprisoned is
because of the uk's failure to pay this
debt that goes back 40 years so it
wasn't a secret that the two things were
linked
president rouhani had mentioned it at
wind and um foreign minister zarif had
also mentioned it so it wasn't a secret
but for some reason it was like hitting
your head against a brick wall because
whenever i brought it up with anyone in
the foreign office they would just deny
the name
ultimately it felt like liz trust did
realize that she had to do something
about the debt in order to bring
nazaneen home she was very clear in the
chamber today that she has paid back the
debt she didn't go into too much detail
about how it was paid but it was
certainly humanitarian aid and that's
why we have nasaline back
when i asked the foreign office earlier
in the week if the debt had been paid
they said they couldn't disclose that
information but having dealt with the
case for six years now i know for a fact
that there's no way a negotiating team
from britain would have been in tehran
if we hadn't paid the debt huge
geopolitics involved behind the scenes
behind a personal and family story and
what about the americans in all this i
mean we understand that originally they
said the uk can't pay this money to iran
because of sanctions they also wanted it
linked to american hostages being held
by the iranians but it seems that that
is not happening
no i think initially it felt like
nazine's case had been been caught up in
the nuclear deal the iranian nuclear
deal now when that president trump
pulled out of that when that fell apart
richard radcliffe's lawyers wrote a very
aggressive and stern lesson to the
government saying you had said nazanin's
case would be resolved along with the
nuclear deal
now what's plan b what are you going to
do now and i think that did get the
government moving because they realized
okay it's not going to be tied to the
nuclear deal because a nuclear deal
hasn't been reinstated
and then they must have worked behind
the scenes and i don't know the details
but it sounded like foreign office
officials have been working behind the
scenes for hours and hours to try and
come up with a creative solution to pay
the debt back but what you say about the
americans is interesting because maura
tabas who is still in iran now he's out
on furlough but he hasn't come back
to the uk is someone who has british
citizenship american citizenship and
iranian citizenship and what i've been
told is that iran is treating him as a
jew national from america and iran and
not as a brit and which is probably why
he hasn't come back to the country i'm
speculating here but it seems strange
that anushia shari and nazanin are now
back and murad still isn't back and it
must be because he is also american and
what about on the personal level let's
uh end it on that uh you must be very
keen yourself to to meet nasan in in the
flesh uh presumably you haven't got any
plans yet you you're going to leave the
the family first of all to to get
through what's going to be a hugely
emotional moment and as i was saying a
bit earlier presumably a little girl
who's going to be staying up very late
this evening into the wee small hours
i just saw gabriella who is a delightful
little girl and i was finally able to
look her in the eye and say
mommy is
really coming home today because i've
said it to her so many times and it's
been a false stones but apparently when
she was first told by her father she
didn't believe him and she thought that
he was pulling her leg
she then started playing the piano
and dancing around the house and being
very sweet when she realized that her
mother was actually coming home when i
saw her the utter look of joy on her
face it was really heartbreaking and
there but on a personal level when
you're an mp in opposition it can be
quite difficult to affect change and
make legislation a lot of times and
today it really feels like i made a
difference through the campaigning not
by myself the whole community and lots
of other people at least i paid a part
in that
here here tulip sadiq very good talking
to you and congratulations on your
tenacity very good talking to you